what a way to bury a story everyone was
ready for the State of the Union speech
last night and Hillary Clinton drops on
her Facebook page at about 8:45 p.m.
this long-winded apology kind of for
botching the sexual harassment complaint
in her 2008 presidential campaign after
a female campaign staffer repeatedly
accused her faith advisor of harassing
her and he wasn't fired joining us now
to discuss that apology drop and other
matters his former adviser to President
Bill Clinton Dick Morris who's the
author of the new book rogue spooks the
intelligence war on Donald Trump dick
Hillary Clinton up to her old tricks you
know document dump on Fridays we used to
document dump on the verdict before the
State of the Union speech what do we
make from this what do we take away from
it well or Hillary Hillary the entire
public persona his bait on this issue is
based on two original lies sometimes
people have original sin she has the
original lies one is that she says bill
didn't do all the stuff he's accused of
doing even though much of it is proven
and secondly she never believed it that
he did and the points of those lies is
that she cannot admit that bill does the
stuff or the she knows about it and lets
him get away with it
because her entire political power is
derivative first ladies aren't elected
it's all derivative of being married to
Clinton and if the marriage just seemed
to be a sham and a fraud she is and
therefore she will do anything put up
with any hypocrisy any lie any
contortion to avoid admitting the truth
well and this other story also kind of
bubbled up today in The Guardian
newspaper and it was like it was all the
old home week and Clinton scandal o'rama
dick because Cody Shearer oh my gosh
that names like web Hubbell Cody Shearer
the MENA airstrip like all this stuff
comes back
Cody Shearer supposedly wrote a second
dossier which kind of confirmed the
first dossier and that
blew up and then but our reporting
indicates that that's there's no there
there
and so we're discounting what the
Guardian reported today however give us
a little background on this Cody Shearer
and why anything he put together about
Donald Trump could probably be dismiss
summarily what Cody is one of the
card-carrying original members of the
black ops team that Hillary developed
over the years to chase down and
blackmail the women with whom bill was
involved to kau them into silence
Kathleen Willey very explicitly mentions
him as part of that and I believe that
this was probably not the second dossier
I think this may have been the first
dossier I think that it's entirely
possible that Hillary and her campaign
people got Shira to come up with these
fantastic stories which all major ones
of which have been totally disproven but
they couldn't release them under Cody
share his name because he had no
credibility at one point he was accused
of negotiating a diplomatic solution in
Bosnia and it had to be repudiated by
the US government and the press knows
all about Shearer you know all about oh
no no it's a lack I needed to find
someone with black ops they needed to
find someone with credibility to be the
front man for that and they made up
chosen Christopher Steele because of his
background in mi6 and it's possible that
the Brits played a role in this
working through Christopher Steele okay
you know we wrote this book rogue spooks
and predicted all of this and and about
the thing that there was basically a
conspiracy against Donald Trump based in
the FBI
and that deep state dig in big holes
dick we're going to have you on radio
tomorrow we talked more about this so
this is a fascinating development and
we're going to stay on this of course